this is like the most exciting day
a baby makes three stassi schroeder and
beau clark have welcomed
their new bundle of joy back in june the
newlyweds who have been dating since
2018
announced they were expecting a baby
girl via instagram
just a few months after having to
postpone their destination wedding
due to the pandemic we've cried about it
we've also laughed about it
we digested it we've come to peace with
it that it might not happen
and you know i get it it's happening to
so many people and there are much
greater things going on in the world
than like your wedding not being able to
work out
but we don't know right now
we're in wedding limbo the two
eventually held a small ceremony
in los angeles back in september and
confirmed the news on the actual
day they were supposed to be married but
their journey to the altar did not come
without controversy
the couple was originally planning to
have a televised wedding on bravo's
vanderpump rules there's nobody else
that i want to spend
the rest of my life with and will you
take this ring
and you marry me oh no
oh my god oh my god are you serious
but in june bravo announced that stasi
would no longer appear on the reality
series
after past racist allegations against
former co-star faith
stowers resurfaced in september she
finally broke her silence on the tamron
hall show
i didn't understand that just because
something wasn't about
race for me doesn't mean it's not about
race
for the other person because i'm
bringing my experience
as a white privileged woman to this
situation and she's bringing her
experience as
a black woman into this situation and
because it's about race for her it
it is about race and and that's
something that
that i've realized stasi also shared
that she wants to learn from her
mistakes and be a better example for her
daughter
i just i want to be a better person i'm
pregnant
and i want my daughter to be proud of me
and i i want to be a part of the
solution i've been a part of the problem
for years now and i i've
recognized that and that's why i say i
don't feel like i'm
a victim of cancer culture people want
me to be mad at it and i'm not
i needed it